dealing with that lineup today is zach
thompson his fourth fourth major league
start he took the loss on father's day
against the cubs but no hits one
unearned run in four innings of work and
uh against a tough lineup then donnie
liked that he was competitive in tough
places against a tough lineup that's a
quote from the manager and today holly
will be another
very tough test for thompson payoff
pitch is in there for a called strike
three that was the cutter
and it froze schwarber when you see that
as a hitter you give up because you see
it outside but it comes back and there's
a perfect pitch and that was i mean as
executed perfectly as you can do it
so here's juan soto in the series a
couple of hits two rbis now
here's the pitch swung on line drive
left center field that is gonna oh it's
missed by sanchez i don't know how it
gets by him turner on his way to third
he makes the turn he's heading home the
relay to the plate is cut off by aguilar
at the mound and in its second is soto
it's the nationals one of the marlins
nothing well good job by juan getting
this ball into the air sanchez had a
beat on it but i think he lost the ball
in the row of lights above the stance
you can see him kind of turn his head at
the last minute the one thing about
playing in indoor stadiums the lights
are kind of low you can see him kind of
duck there and close his eyes
two-strike pitch thompson to castro
swinging the miss he struck
but
the nationals get a run
14 fastball sinker and that patented
patrick slider
that he throws down the end to
right-handed hitters to keep him off
balance but the key for him is throwing
strike one and getting out of this first
ending cleanly
marlon saw him a little earlier this
season jazz testing the corner that'll
get down and get to the wall he gets
hung underneath the padding down there
and jazz is not going to stop at second
here comes the throw it's late and jazz
with a lead off triple
now that's the kind of response you're
looking for from jazz at top this lineup
good counter punch to start this ball
game drives it into the right field
corner with toes crunch guys down there
ate up the baseball and helped him get
over to third i love it starling martay
starling has the average at 312 has
yet to get a hit in this series however
has reached base
pokes went out to second base that
should get the job done martay drives
home the equalizer
perfect example of seeing that the
infield is back just put the ball to
play against the run hole
now to right field soto back it's over
his head it's going to run off the wall
hey suzaku
and he will get there
second extra base hit for the marlins in
this first off of patrick
one-two delivery swing and a miss struck
him out on a slider short-hopped by
corbin puts the tag on duval for out
number two
so does miguel rojas stands and he lines
one to right center field that's getting
down for base hit soto cuts it around
third aguilar he's racing home and the
throws into second base it's a two-out
rbi single from miguel rojas and the
marlins grab a 2-1 lead if i were to
patent the swing or or name the swing
that rojas is most known for but you
just saw it it's that approach there
fastball middle middle away
lining the ball to the right center
field gap that's kind of his thing
second against zach thompson and on one
two there's called strike three got him
looking into curve he now has three well
he just locked him up
right out of the batter's box swinging a
miss and a breaking ball struck him out
on the slider
two two pitch schwarber takes straight
three called a good looking curve he's
struck out looking both times that's
five k's already for zach thompson 2-2
pitch and thompson curve in there for
strike three call just like the
curveball he caught schwarber looking on
now he gets soto
corbin trying for his second straight
one two three inning he brings it home
swinging a miss 95 on the fastball blew
it by duvall and corbin has settled in
retiring seven in a row after a very
rough start
you know there's some guys who actually
do this all the time bell is one of them
and a miss another strikeout for
thompson he's got seven to match a
career high i mean he's got it all
working this is the two-seater he didn't
throw this too often
the 1-1
ew look out gomes is hit by a pitch that
was a curveball that got away and gomez
tried to duck underneath it and it
grazed him on the
on the back
here's castro and castro lines one for a
base in a left center field up the alley
marty does he caught it off we can't see
him now the ball gets away golem's
racing for third is going to try to
score here's the relay throw home from
rojas gomes slides in safely and the
nationals have tied the game well let's
see who's playing soccer out here yep
starlin marte
a little back hill there
second time through the order
corbin deals and he struck him out
swinging with a slider so three sliders
three swings and misses
birdie bounced to second his first time
uh went two for four had an rbi stolen
base and scored a run in the 11-2 win
last night now he muzzles the ball deep
to right field chasing soto at the wall
goodbye john bernie for the lead it's
3-2 marlins wow jb that's some power
how about this a no doubter to right
field
john gomes the runner at first two balls
two strikes
and a swing and a miss zach thompson 11
strikeouts a season high for the marlins
this year
what a day
zack attack
just love what he did he got away from
the cutter and that's exactly what dom
natalie wanted fastball's up to then
tunnel that big 12-6 breaker it was just
incredible with it prior to today he had
three strikeouts only on that curveball
seven strikeouts of the 11 came off the
breaking ball
the 1-1 line drive left field this is
going to be a base hit toward the line
long run to get it for sanchez he'll
pick it up deep in the corner along the
warning track
and harrison jogs into second with a
lead off doubles
garrett cooper's in the on deck circle
that's the pitcher spot that's due up
next if birdie can't extend this inning
which he will makes it into center field
and he is going to take a turn
and get to second base
taking nothing for granted a hustle
double for john now this is what you
were talking about when we said these
these are the plays that john
brings to the table and how he impacts a
uh well a game
three two one on one out ninth inning
here we go swinging a miss he struck him
out at 95. he hadn't shown him a
fastball and on 3-2 he blows it by him
two outs in the ninth harrison leads
from first carrying the tying run the
1-0 pitch turner pops it in the air
right side of the infield aguilar called
off by chisholm jazz got it and the
marlins win
what an escape back by the marlins
bender in the seventh floro in the
eighth garcia in the ninth saving the
game for zach thompson and the marlins
win a second game in a row from the
nationals a thriller at lone depot park
on this saturday afternoon
three to the final